(suspenseful music)
- [Abbi] You been to a psychic ?
- [Ilana] No, but I've always w.
- Prophecy... I'm feeling
you're gonna die today.
- [Man] I lost the heartbeat
(screaming)
- You fucking monster, you killn
- No, I would never...
- [Mugger] I'm mugging you bitc.
(scissors snapping)
- [Abbi] My pony!
(scream)
- [Ilana] I have a bad cavity
that needs to get drilled.
(screaming)
- [Lincoln] Are you for real?
- What the (beep) this?
- No.
(slap)
(screaming)
(creepy music)
- Jaime, Jimmels.
Jaime?
Jimmels?
Jaime, what happened?
(tense, loud chords)
- Help me!
(scream)
- Monsters!
- [Abbi] Oh my God!
- I think this is the moment th.
- [Ilana] My mom's gonna be so .
(screaming)
- [Abbi] We're okay, take my ha.
- [Creepy Voice] Where you been?